[Music]
[Music]
selena gomez giving fans a glimpse into
her mental health journey in a teaser
for her upcoming apple tv plus
documentary my mind and me i'm very
honest though in general the singer
shares some of her most vulnerable
moments and even cries
i think that for me i'm really big on
vulnerability the doc follows selena's
years in the limelight and how she
navigated stardom along with an
unexpected shift in her life
it spans over six years highlighting the
journey to the current phase in her
career
selena shared the teaser to instagram
writing a candid message alongside it
quote we don't get along sometimes and
it gets hard to breathe but i wouldn't
change my life
i feel like this time i'm just so
confident and comfortable and i feel
free more than i've ever felt in my
whole life selena's never shied away
from opening up about how she's taken
the steps to put herself first
i'm constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel like all right what could
i be better at what could i do better at
where
where could my confidence be stronger
the singer and executive producer who's
opened up about her own struggles with
social media in the past spoke with e.t
about the message she hopes to send to
young kids
i think people are really scared to to
be honest with themselves and
strength is looked upon as oh i'm strong
i don't need anything i can't i can
handle everything and that's just not
the truth and i think kids especially
with social media sometimes they just
feel a little claustrophobic and i don't
think their voice is actually being
heard and i think that's the message i
want i want people to know that every
every single life is valuable that their
voice can be heard and that there are
people who are willing to be there for
them
[Music]
you